[Music]
meagan markle's dad claims he once
dramatically hung up on Prince Harry
potato interesting conversations on the
phone thomas marco is back on the press
circuit sharing new details on a phone
call he had with the duke and duchess of
sussex ahead of their royal wedding in a
new interview with the Daily Mail he
recalls talking to Prince Harry before
he was accused of staging paparazzi
photos quote Harry told me that I should
never go to the press he said they will
eat you alive he was right it was giving
me advice about the press the 74 year
old claims Harry called him back later
to address the paparazzi scandal while
he was recovering from a heart attack
reportedly telling Thomas quote if you
had listened to me this would never have
happened
thomas claims he replied maybe it would
be better for you guys if i was dead
then you could pretend to be sad and
then he hung up on Harry
last week a source told ET Duchess Megan
hasn't spoken to her father since her
wedding and remains hurt that her father
keeps talking to the press
adding the palace is at a loss of what
to do and is reevaluating options how do
you feel about Thomas Merkel's inability
to keep his mouth shut I feel sorry for
him and you know I've got to say that
Megan I think is handled is really badly
Pierce Morgan recently shared his
thoughts with ET about Megan and
Thomas's relationship he has said this
week that he's been cut off from the
palace he can't get in touch with his
daughter do you think there will ever be
a reconciliation I think it's tough you
know I think that she's clearly taken a
view he's bad news for her he's trouble
but my message to megan is he's your dad
he's not well
[Music]